these celebs are stripping down on  social media curves or edges or perfect  imperfection Chrissy Teigen went nude  safe for a little coverage by hubby John  Legend  to celebrate her friends of bday on  Instagram it's unclear why she had to be  naked but we'll take it bella thorne  rocked just a bra and her boyfriend -  Tyler posies boxers for some sort of  secret shoot possibly a music video for  the Teen Wolf star and Faith Hill  snapped a sneaky shot of her hubby Tim  McGraw here he is a shirtless washing  faith's car so she can go see Adele in  Nashville faith captioned her pic yes  baby scrub those tires the couple just  celebrated their 20th anniversary handed  told et that they had a big plans for  the big day DJ's  you